an entire poi flower made up of nothing
but bending planes
sounds wild but that's the beauty of
toroids toroids will really add
dimension to your spinning but they can
also be really tricky to learn
we're going to start with iso bends drex
here from drexfactor poi sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
arts to benefit your body and brain
in this video i want to introduce you to
the world of toroids through isobends
and yes i'm going to explain what all of
these words mean have no fear before we
dive in though i do just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca becklin thank you
all so very much for your support for my
work and my mission
a couple months ago i uploaded a video
talking about that lost gem of the
techpoi world toroids
and i was shocked when it got a really
positive reaction i'll link to it down
in the description as well as up in the
cards if you're watching on youtube
turns out there are people out there
still interested in toroids who knew
so by popular request i'm going to do a
series of tutorials outlining the basic
concepts and applications for them
starting with this one so to start let's
do just a little bit of review what
exactly is a toroid toroids are a type
of 3d poi flower that briefly became
popular in the tech poi world back in
the early 2010s that involve spinning
the poi head over the surface of an
invisible donut the theory is that we
are trying to spin the plane of the poi
in the same fashion that we would the
poi itself resulting in some pretty
exotic poi patterns that rely heavily on
plane bending if you're unfamiliar with
the concepts of poi planes poi flowers
or plane bending please check out my
intro playlist that i'll link to down in
the description as well as up in the
cards if you're watching on youtube okay
so what makes an isobend toroid unique
in isobentoroids we think of the plane
of the poi as spinning in the same
direction that the hand is moving in and
completing a single rotation in the same
amount of time
it is analogous to an extension in
classical poi spinning but the movement
of the plane is mostly in the
imagination the flow artist performing
the isobentoroid knowing that the plane
of the poi is behaving like an extension
that just leaves us with the question of
how many times the poi will complete a
spin through that donut
for iso bends the answer is typically
four to visualize this think of a hoop
as being the plane of the poi and as we
spin it around on edge towards the
audience we think of there being four
discrete points that we want to make
sure we hit with the poi
bottom
side top and side
those moments when the four positions of
the hoop seem to overlap in the middle
are where we switch the poi between
planes so no matter what the poi should
always appear to be moving in more or
less a straight line relative to the
audience so how exactly do we accomplish
these plane bends well first we have to
familiarize ourselves with how these
bends feel because they're going to be a
huge adjustment for us start off by
bending back and forth between the
bottom position and the one off to your
right side
you'll want to start with the poi
spinning forward in what feels like a
buzz saw plane with your hand hovering
down near your waist as the poi reaches
the top of its swing near your body's
center you're going to move your hand
out to the side at shoulder level and
yank the poi along with it
but do not stall the poi keep it
spinning in a horizontal plane you
should arrive in a position with your
hand off to the right and the poi now
spinning in a horizontal plane
if you were to look up at the poi
spinning from underneath it would appear
to be spinning counterclockwise
note that both when the poi is spinning
forward near your waist and
counterclockwise to your side the poi
will be swinging out away from you as it
approaches the center of your body
this is an important landmark to keep in
mind practice switching back and forth
between these two different positions
hand low poi spinning forward and buzz
saw and hand at shoulder level spinning
the poi counterclockwise
you can start by spinning the poi three
times in each position and then work
your way down to two beats and finally
switch straight back and forth for 10
reps
so already this is probably going to
feel really strange there are some
similarities to what we're used to when
we perform weaves and bend between
parallel planes but bending between
planes that are an angle to each other
is an entirely different experience but
wait
we also have three other bends to work
through as well for our next bend we're
going to start from that position with
our hand off to the side and the poi
spinning counterclockwise
when the poi head passes through our
body center we're gonna yank our hand up
above our head on the center line of our
body and pull the poi upward as it spins
out away from us
this will result in us spinning the poi
in buzz saw plane once again but this
time near head level and the poi will
appear to be spinning reverse instead of
forwards just like with our first bend
drill this bend by hanging out in each
position first for three beats and then
switching to the next before going down
to two beats and then just switching
back and forth see if you can get in 10
reps of the bend to get it down in
muscle memory congratulations we are now
halfway through our iso bend now let's
work our way back down the other side
starting from keeping the poi spinning
in reverse in buzzsaw plane up near your
head
wait for the poi to swing out away from
you as it reaches the bottom of its path
and swing your hand out to the side at
shoulder level and pull the poi into a
horizontal plane
try to make sure you wind up with the
poi spinning what would appear to be
clockwise if you looked up at it from
below
you'll know you've got it right because
once again the poi will be swinging out
away from you as it passes through body
center practice going back and forth
between these two positions reverse and
buzz saw plane up top and clockwise and
horizontal plane over at your left
i often find it helpful when drilling
this bend to make sure that the poi
winds up spinning underneath my hand and
arm as it goes through the horizontal
plane and now for our final bend we have
to get back to the position that we
started in from that clockwise position
off to our left we have to do something
that's going to feel quite odd
as the poi head passes through body
center we're going to let it shoot
straight out in front of us and then
just drop
we drop our hand down near our hips
along our body's center line and we
should wind up with the poi spinning
forwards and buzz slot plane right where
we started i honestly find this plane
bend to feel the strangest personally
there's something about that drop when
it just lands back in buzzsaw plane that
feels like it shouldn't be right to me
but here we are
like the other bends try to get in 10
reps of this one so now that we have
down all four plane bends it's time to
put them all together start off by
performing each bend three times before
switching to the next one in order from
there you can drop down to two reps per
bend and then see if you can just move
continuously through this isobend toroid
one important thing that is super
important to keep in mind as you're
drilling this you can think of the
center of the donut as being a point
that's being projected out away from the
place where your collarbones meet
whenever the poi head is passing through
the center of that donut it is always
swinging away from you this should give
you a way to check for yourself whether
you're performing each bin properly or
not now i will confess that i learned
plane braking before i learned toroids
so it took me a long time and a lot of
practice to start to make these plane
bends feel normal rather than just
simply trying to stall the poi every
time they went through the center
remember the point is to keep the poi
moving the entire time don't let it stop
at any point cool so you've got down a
basic isobend toroid now what can you
actually do with it
well the same thing we do with every poi
flower pinky try to take over timing and
direction world
just like any other type of flower you
can drill iso bend toroids with both
hands to get down all timing and
direction modes
work to get both hands working together
in together time same direction
[Music]
as well as together time opposite
directions
[Applause]
[Music]
split time opposite directions
[Applause]
[Music]
and split time same direction
[Applause]
now one thing that's super exciting
about learning how to do all these
different flowers with toroids is that
they actually make transitions between
different timing and direction modes
really easy
you never have to stall the poi or do
pendulums to switch their direction you
just opt to bend back through the last
plane and voila you've switched the
direction your hand is moving without
doing anything at all to the momentum of
the poi
to my eyes this makes timing and
direction changes with toroids look
smooth in a way that they don't with
traditional poi spinning you're probably
going to find as i did when i undertook
learning toroids in all these modes that
your hands don't always produce clean
planes in the same spots at the same
time and you know what
that's okay it just takes practice to
clean things up and get these down but
there is another direction to take this
in that i want to run by you as well so
remember how the way we drilled our iso
bends meant that the poi was always
swinging away from us through the center
of the doughnut
whale we can actually perform iso bends
with the poi always swinging towards us
through the donut instead too the
technique for learning these iso bends
is exactly the same too you just reverse
what direction the poi was spinning at
all of those individual points so you go
from reverse on bottom to clockwise on
the right forward on top and
counterclockwise to your left though do
note that from the perspective of your
audience it looks identical to the
version with the poi swinging away from
you in the center i personally think of
these as being two expressions of
iso-bend toroids the audi and the any
depending upon which direction the poi
is going through the middle so why
bother learning both aside from bragging
rights it does actually open up a few
more options to be able to do both
let's say you're performing an innie
with one hand and an audi with the other
that means that if you are in together
opposites that the poi will be spinning
in split time same direction when you're
in horizontal plane and you can easily
make transitions to more traditional poi
tricks from here so like that's a lot a
brand new type of poi flower that
requires some very new information for
your body and brain to learn some cool
timing and direction possibilities with
it as well as two different expressions
that can open up transitions back and
forth to more traditional poi tricks
this is kind of a big elephant to
swallow in one bite so take your time
with it and i dearly hope this means
i'll see more of y'all out there getting
bit by the toroid bug
go break some eggs
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and to help my channel grow
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description helped to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more
i'm on a mission to bring poi spinning
and flow arts to the wider world and
help people connect with their brains
and their bodies
so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that in the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if
you're watching on youtube there you can
get access to a whole host of rewards
and help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to see more videos on toroids i've
got a playlist of older videos on the
topic that i'll link to down below as
well as up on screen if you're watching
on youtube
speaking of the youtube algorithm thinks
based upon your viewing habits that
you'll also like this top video so that
might be worth checking out as well make
sure to get outside to flow today and
i'll see you with a new video on monday
thanks for watching and have a good one
peace